bonjour thomas baroque alors aujourd'hui
nous entamons notre huitième semaine de
confinement comment ça va ça va bien ça
va bien je suis chez moi je suis dans de
bonnes conditions puisque j'ai la chance
d'avoir un jardin j'ai une maison avec
pas mal de place
j'ai les moyens de continuer à
m'entraîner je suis en télétravail
donc globalement je suis pas à plaindre
et je supporte plutôt bien ces semaines
de confinement alors justement quand on
fait de l'aviron comment on fait pour
continuer à s'entraîner en étant confiné
alors on s'entraîne pas en bateau ça
c'est sûr on n'a pas de dérogation ou
d'autorisation particulière en tant que
sportif de haut niveau je m'entraîne sur
ergomètre donc ces rameurs
d'appartements qui simule assez bien le
mouvement de l'aviron avec beaucoup de
paramètres techniques qui sont pas là
mais au niveau physiologie ça fait
vraiment bien le travail
et puis je fais aussi du vélo pas mal
vélo d'appartement et puis de la
musculation que mon club m'a permis de
d'embarquer un peu de matériel juste
avant le début du confinement pour
pouvoir faire ça à la maison
vous savez un planning précis
entraînement le matin une pause
entraînement l'après-midi comment ça se
passe oui effectivement j'ai une
organisation de la journée qui ressemble
à peu près ce qui se passe quand on
n'est pas en perdre de confinement à
seule différence et qui a pas les
déplacements
je m'entraîne le matin alors soit en
début de matinée soit en fin de matinée
ses dépens un peu de de l'humeur de la
forme et puis des rendez vous que je
peux avoir niveau professionnel aussi je
fais des jeunes normalement j'ai une
petite sieste après je recommence à
travailler
et puis je suis le deuxième entraînement
en fin de fin d'après midi début de
soirée je suis dans la durée donc j'ai
des journées qui ressemble quand même
pas mal à ce que je fais habituellement
la différence près du déplacement sept
restent en contact ces masques ainsi
avec votre collègue qui appliquent les
mêmes règles que vous les mêmes règles
d'entraînement que voici
oui alors de toute façon au niveau
national on a en un programme qui est le
même pour tous les rameurs on a toujours
des contacts avec nos coachs niveau de
la fédération donc donc colas et chacun
organise un peu ces journées comme il le
peut et comme il le veut nous sommes ses
contraintes mais le problème
entraînement à peu près équivalent
emportements bien sûr vous deviez
participer au prochain aux prochains
jeux olympiques à tokyo qui ont été
reportée d'un an raison évidemment de la
crise sanitaire
comment vous avez réagi à cette annonce
alors je sais un petit peu à raccourci
dire que je devais y participent et
j'espère pouvoir y participer
l'essai que je n'étais pas encore bouclé
les qualifications du bateau était pas
encore obtenu
donc on en était pas encore directement
à se préoccuper des jeux olympiques on
était plutôt à se préoccuper de pouvoir
et alors c'est sûr que avec les
premières la première nouvelle qui a été
annoncée c'était l'annulation des
régates de la régate de qualification
donc potentiellement une qualification
sur tapis vert ce qui nous arrangeait
pas beaucoup parce que le bateau
français était pas bien parti pour se
qualifier de cette façon là donc ça a
été un peu un soulagement en tout cas de
se dire qu on avait à nouveau nos
chances et notre destin entre nos mains
maintenant
je ne sais toujours pas quelle va être
quelles vont être les modalités de
sélection au niveau national pour
l'année prochaine et encore moins de
qualification pour les as dans la vie
même si on se dit que avec le temps
qu'on s'est laissé potentiellement
pourrait repartir enfin copier ce qui
était prévu pour cette année pour
l'année prochaine mais c'est encore un
point d'interrogation pour l'instant on
ne sait pas et c'est à peu près normal
parce que je pense que personne ne sait
vraiment à quoi va ressembler les
semaines et encore moins les mois à
venir
alors justement après le longe mais dont
la date a en théorie évidemment du début
du de déconfinement est ce que vous avez
eu des précisions concernant votre
entraînement est ce que ce sera possible
à l'extérieur par exemple
non j'ai pas vraiment une précision j'ai
juste eu un communiqué de presse du
ministère des sports
en plus moi je suis dans une situation
un peu particulière puisque je
m'entraîne dans le parc du château de
versailles
donc qui est un autre qui est fermé en
ce moment qui va potentiellement le
reste est donc qu'est-ce que je vais
réussir à être considéré comme un
sportif professionnel à ce titre-là
avoir le droit de me déplacer et d'y
accéder pour travailler et donc pour
m'entraîner pour l'instant c'est encore
des des interrogations j'ai contacté des
personnes qui doivent prendre cette
décision est pour l'instant à temps mais
c'est vrai qu'à une semaine du
déconfinement je ne sais pas vraiment
quoi va ressembler la semaine prochaine
bon après quelques jours de plus sur le
rite qui vient de s'écouler pendant les
huit semaines ça sera pas un drame le
pense vous avez hâte j'imagine quand
même de confinement de retrouver
justement le contact avec l'eau par
exemple
oui effectivement c'est ce qui manque le
plus les sensations qu'on peut avoir en
bateau on les retrouve nulle part
ailleurs donc et donc c'est clair que
c'est quelque chose qui finit par
manquer après c'est pas plus mal le fait
que que ça manque un peu parce qu'on se
rappelle sa part et se rappeler pourquoi
on aime ce sport pour qu'on aime aller à
l'entraînement
c'est vrai que ça fait quelques années
maintenant que j'aurais plutôt une
carrière un peu longue maintenant et
donc je plutôt content d'enfin comptant
dans la mesure du possible mais c'est
pas plus mal finalement 7,7 couplé à un
peu forcé